[Music]
that time has arrived yes friend and you
are here it's been many years in the
making it's so true I've been looking
forward to this for a very long time I'm
delighted that you're here and I want to
just say before we even do anything this
[ __ ] book is an awesome dude
you did an amazing job and I think it's
going to inspire and help so many people
so hats off thank you so much it really
is an accomplishment when people ask me
you know what are the most influential
books in your life there's that list is
long but generally at or near the top of
that list is always the war of art
turning pro and the artists way like the
three primers that I returned to year
after year after year to stoke my
creativity and you know refresh my
perspective those are timeless works but
they were also written years ago right
and I look at this book as perfectly
positioned to you know be the modern
iteration those timeless primers well
that is that's huge thank you for saying
that and I will also confess that those
those books were influential in me and
my career we talked about it on my show
last year and and yet I also felt like
there was a gap between where those
books stopped and modern culture right
and new tools and it didn't talk about a
lot of the both things that can set
creators and entrepreneurs free and also
the things that trap us mm-hmm there's
just some like constraints that are out
there in the world or that we place on
ourselves that didn't get brought up in
some of those books I felt like there
was a little bit of a gap and I also
like you know you you wrote an amazing
book if to go deep yeah you know and
it's there's a ton of research and the
research has takes many forms right the
research is your own personal experience
as your own empirical experiences you
look at see talk to your community all
the people have been on my show on
creativeLIVE you in particular like
those that conversation impacted me and
you start to see patterns and you start
to see windows and you start to see
cracks that
need to be open and Craxton need to be
filled and so it was a fascinating
process to be writing a book about
creativity and creating something yeah
cycle on that for a second well meta is
a big theme of your whole career right
there's a definitely a meta aspect to
that and I think you're absolutely
correct like those other books they are
they're timeless perhaps by virtue of
the fact that that you can't you can't
specify when they were written yeah but
our culture has shifted and changed the
gatekeepers are gone the tools of
creativity are more accessible than ever
there's a more there's a democratization
of this universe that didn't exist back
then that makes that I think has
stimulated and motivated and inspired a
lot of people to think about creative
creativity more broadly you know that
and and whether that means quitting your
job to be an artist or just finding a
hobby or like you know being intentional
about the images you put on Instagram
sure these are all aspects of creativity
and and and really what you've done is
broad in the aperture on what creativity
means while also underscoring the
importance of it in everyday life for
everybody no matter who you are if you
took that away I am done no that's
examining literally you just sort of you
know I don't even need to introduce the
book because that is the the ethos
behind the book that was you know
specifically broadening the aperture on
creativity because right now there's
people going away I don't know if I'm
not really identified as creator I'm an
attorney or I'm an account interim
whoever's listening and it's like no no
this is exactly why you and if you're if
you're a creator you identify as that
great this is like right in your sweet
spot but there's a whole universe of
people who are what I call creative
curious that understand that there's
some power there that I can't kind like
the Jena Seiko I don't know how to grab
on to it and I want to understand that a
little bit more and when you broaden
that definition of what creativity is
which to me is part of the challenge
that we've had historically with how art
and creativity have been viewed in our
culture when you broaden the aperture a
little bit you can all sudden sink your
teeth into it and find immense
and powerful meaning mm-hmm yeah I think
historically the word creative or
creativity isn't necessarily pejorative
but it's exclusionary people either
identify with that or they don't or
they're scared of it yeah
and in truth it is it is part and parcel
of what makes us human
it is a universal aspect of the
condition of being in one of these
bodies yeah literally we are creating
machines and that's part of like
expanding the definition to understand
that wait a minute you know that my
decisions on which how to get to your
house today do I go here this way or
that way the what I you know decide to
do with my day in my time on a on a
minute-by-minute basis but also on a
life scale basis like those are all
wickedly
wildly creative acts that have been
discarded into like you know if you were
thinking of a mineral pathway it's just
like the base neural pathway that you
always go but there's an opportunity for
in all of those places to do something
different and when you start to realize
that this creativity in small daily
doses is the same exact muscle that we
use to create our life it's just
creativity different scale your head
starts to go like okay ready to pay
attention here right well so then if I
was to ask you how you define creativity
what is the response to that it's such a
the way that I approach it is so simple
it may be painful for some people but
it's the act of putting two things that
might not have gone together just a
moment ago of putting those two things
together to create something new and
useful mm-hmm so it is a very broad
definition but that's to me what
actually makes the book really relevant
because there are people like this is
not about changing your lifestyle this
is not about moving to Barry and wearing
a beret and smoking a cigarette in
Canada if that's your deal totally it
can be but it's also doesn't have to be
about a new set of friends instead it's
a new way of operating it's a new way of
seeing what's in front of you and you
know just at a super top level it's like
I operate from the principle that a
every person is creative that it's the
thing that separates us from every other
species on the planet mhm and it is it's
fun I'll just walk into any first-grade
classroom right who wants to come at the
front of the room and draw me a picture
every hand goes up and then do the same
thing with the sixth-grade class and
then a ninth grade class and you see
that we're this is a thing that is
innate and we're training it out of us
of if that's principle one principle -
sorry one is that we're just creativity
every person - is the creativity is a
muscle it's a habit not a skill it's a
process not a product it's a muscle and
I guess Maya Angelou said it well like
the more you use the more you have right
think about training or anything else
right so it becomes more available to us
and then if you follow one and two the
simple argument number three is so then
all these small creative acts that we do
every day yes playing the guitar making
a meal building a family writing code
yes those things are literally the
things that are going to give you the
insight that you have agency /
creativity with a capital C like
creating the arc of your life mm-hmm so
to me that like it's from a very simple
definition you just have to make a
simple three-step argument and all of a
sudden you're at this like I need to pay
attention yeah that creativity is a non
depleting renewable resource that it's
not something that certain people are
struck with but that they cultivate
through a deliberate and intentional
practice over time yeah that is divorced
from the results of it and all about the
process of doing like it's not fake it
till you make it it's make it till you
make it so the process of being a maker
in whatever form that is for you yeah
yeah and when you think about it like
let's let's talk about it away from the
sort of small C creativity of making a
meal or building a business or whatever
and talk about it on the life scale the
people that you are inspired by that you
moved by that you're connected to that
you
meir their lives were created
intentionally there's all kinds of
circumstances but they created the
puzzle that is their life and there
they're expressing themselves in a
particular way it's intentional it's
designed and it's created it's not just
you just fell into this thing one day
and right and so when you start to look
at creativity with that sort of capital
C on the life arc you know like who do I
am and it doesn't need to be someone
famous or fancy in the internet or or
some you know well known entrepreneur
artist it can be your next-door neighbor
that lives in amazing integrity and and
they have a mindfulness about them then
you really like that's not an accident
that was created that person set out
with a vision for themselves and slowly
but surely got there there was no
overnight there was no it was a creative
process and that's available to you yeah
we don't do we're very good at
celebrating you know the masters of our
culture and you know across all
disciplines but we're not very good at
peeling the layers back and really
objectively examining the journey
required to get to that place and that
leaves us as a culture with this false
sensibility that these people just came
out fully baked and they you know
they're touched by God in a certain way
that were not totally and what is your
what do your parents say oh go to
Harvard then you know go to get this
degree and then have this job and then
because and that's gonna and you're like
wait a minute the people that I admire
most of them didn't do any of that right
in fact they led this really disjointed
like weird puzzle that they put together
over time they didn't do acts they
didn't do why or they did it part way
and then they quit or and what parent is
coaching their child to do that ya know
nobody nobody's I mean very rare people
are I mean that that's very similar to I
just put up a podcast yesterday with
David Epstein I wrote this book range
and he deconstructs the career paths of
all these amazing people to to kind of
upend the theory the 10,000 hour rule
that basically these people weren't
people that just ground themselves down
you know to become great at what they do
at the exclusion of everything but
actually live very broad lives in which
they had many different kinds of
experiences that ultimately inform their
craft and elevate it beyond their peers
yeah like so true and to me that is they
are crafting that you know there they
are saying I'm taking a little bit from
this and a little bit from that and yet
to me this is a sort of really
fundamental piece of the book and look
at right now if you're sitting there
judging your life like oh my gosh I am
the person he described I did what was
prescribed and I don't worry that's the
culture is designed to do that you're
not a weirdo in fact you're normal and
what we're trying to do here is to get
you to see this framework and realize
that you have some power to change it at
whatever stage here and take it from me
like I did all the mistakes I've like
hundreds of thousands in debt and
student loan 10 years off course doing
everybody else's think 10 years you
think at the end of my life I'm gonna
say like I got you Pete there yeah but I
I mean honestly with that part of like
what why I feel like we can act when
when we're together it's like there's a
there's a shared sort of like oh my gosh
I did yeah I think when you're in it you
can't see it the only looking back in
retrospect we look at your career and
you see oh all these dominoes line up
perfectly to you know create this person
that is Chase Jarvis when you're working
in the ski shop or what are you you're
not you're not consciously aware that
this is all going into the hopper and is
gonna pay dividends later you're like
what the hell what am i right right and
that's so you know that's both I want to
be to frame it as hey you might have not
intended to be where you are right now
but it's never too late to sort of shift
gears and whatever you have in your
backpack is gonna be very valuable on
your journey forward because especially
if you can shift gears into this act of
creating and the next chapter your life
rather than being the cork and the tide
and that you ended up here wherever here
is
don't worry like to me that's a really
important thing to grasp for every one
or almost every one there's a gap
between where you are and where you want
to be and it's just what we need is a
framework of a thinking about it and
then be getting there and that's
part of what I tried to bake into the
book yeah and it's it's primarily
prescriptive but there's this kind of
subplot of memoir that it's threaded
through it like it's not overtly a
memoir but you you divert from the
prescription from time to time to go
into these you know link these stories
of pivotal moments in your life that
help kind of underscore the point that
you're trying to make and if you looked
at them as a unit in themselves they're
all things that historically would be
massive diversions or things that were a
part of what you shouldn't do and so
that's like I'm trying to there's
nothing more than books that are like
okay take a perfect little acorn a and
then if you take perfect acorn a and you
do B C D and E with it you're gonna get
this great oak tree FGH yeah life is
messy creativity is even messier totally
and so I'm like through my own because
like I don't wanna throw rocks at other
folks so through my own sort of messy
path I tried to deconstruct that and
deconstruct the lives of people that I
admire and know well and that I've had
the chance to be around or study or
create cultivate with and it just so
happens that there's a real pattern of
recognition deciding even think of your
journey it's the same thing like we did
what we did we recognized some stuff we
made some changes the cool part is well
we might be 10,000 hours for ten years
or five minutes or eight books or
whatever away from what we see for
ourselves a number of decisions it can
be like a single digit one or two or
three decisions away from an entirely
radically different life and to me that
is exciting and powerful yeah I mean
I've you know I'm a living example of
that you're you are as well and and I
think you know one of the reasons why I
also feel like we're kindred spirits is
that despite the fact that our stories
and our career paths in many ways are
very different and our upbringings are
very different there's a lot of
similarities yeah in our story and the
more I dive into you know your path the
more I was struck by how similar they
are so like let's let's go back to the
alright way back yonder the son of a cop
and a mom who works in a biotech company
I mean you grew up only child and and
and you know I don't want to project
here but perhaps millions perhaps
somewhat perhaps like a sensitive and
creative child who also had prowess as
an athlete and maybe the first big
choice that you had to make was who am i
identifying with and what tribe do I
want to belong to yeah and I think this
is part of like in the particular lies
the universal right my story is in
second grade
miss Kelly I'll never forget her I loved
her as a teacher she was amazing and I
also that was when I was second grade
was like I just did my first film it was
called the Sons of Zorro we washed cars
in the neighborhood a gang of us got
together we bought eight millimeter
Super eight film you know asked a
buddy's brother to film us wrote a
little script and did costumes recorded
this film developed it screened it and
actually made more money than we spread
so like maybe 30 bucks and it cost 50
Larry Robert Rodriguez yeah well there
you go
and so in about that time and then I
roll into second grade I'm like god this
is amazing I'm performing magic tricks
for my friends at school I had a comic
strip that I did every week with my
character's name was Clyde then I took
Clyde through a bunch of different like
aspects of his life and then the
parent-teacher conference happened and I
was around because it was also an ice
cream social going on and and I
overheard miss Kelly telling my parents
chase is so much better at sports than
he is at art ooh and at the moment I
actually wasn't even hurt I was like
note to self
change gears because what do we want to
do one sentence yeah and as
eight-year-olds we'll again we're social
animals we want acceptance we want to
fit in we don't want to disappoint and
my story might be about miss Kelly in
second grade but the reality is we've
always got we got all of us have some
aspect of that story and maybe it's not
one moment maybe it's ten moments and
there was a bunch of
other moments but I just I did I ran to
sports and to be crystal clear has
served me very well I went to college on
a soccer scholarship played and lipid
development soccer team like it did
everything that culture said it was
going to do and yet what did i do what
did i turn my back on i turned my back
and I was even cognizant of it because
the thing that I chose certainly well I
didn't feel like I missed it but when my
grandfather died whatever it was 12
something 8 years 10 years later dropped
dead of a heart attack when I was a week
before my college graduation I was just
completely struck he was a amateur
photographer he had taken pictures of me
growing up my soccer games he and my
father we used to treat pictures and and
the obviously was horrible but the
silver lining was that I was given his
cameras and it was like I was
transported back to that second grade
and like wait a minute what I've I've
always been curious about this
skateboard culture gave me a little hint
of it as a little skater Punk and it was
like spray paint and punk rock and the
DIY ethos something like I started
feeling that a little bit
but then it was really like okay you're
gonna be a skateboarder are you gonna go
you know try out for the Olympics
development soccer team and so to me I
mean a choice then but until that moment
where my grandfather died and I was
given his cameras I really had turned my
back on this thing largely to fit in and
I don't think it's that unusual when I
look back at other people's stories
whether it was partying or whether it
was going to the right college or
there's just so many shoulds and oughts
and musts that we get in our culture
yeah and especially when they come from
people that we love that we respect and
admire and what do they want for us
they're not trying to get you to not be
an awesome creator they're trying to get
you to be more like them more like the
images that they see on TV which is
average well they're afraid you know
they just want the best for you as long
as it there they're terrified about the
uncertainty that
that comes with you know blazing a
unique path so it's it's
well-intentioned it's not malevolent or
anything having that and to me the guys
this is that's worth talking about yeah
these people are not trying there's no
evil genius they're not trying to
repress you nor its culture they want
the best for you of course around in
their own way but in any event somehow
comes right it becomes more incumbent
upon you to develop that sense of self
that can lead you on your own unique
path and that's difficult and you know
for me it came much later than it did
for you but what's interesting about
that story and I've heard you tell it
before you gloss over one aspect of it
which is this it
what feels like an assumption like a you
so you you're gifted the these cameras
from your grandfather
so obviously this was a message from the
universe but but you know it could have
very easily just been like oh thanks and
go about your way like this yeah or put
them in your closet or something like
that so to me what I hear in that is
that that creative Sensibility albeit
repressed was percolating just beneath
the surface and unconsciously or
consciously you are almost looking for
an excuse to explore it and I think that
is a very common paradigm that's part of
why the book exists and to me that you
know again if you assume that first
principle that there's creativity inside
of every person and that create and that
culture shapes it in a way that it does
so that we fit into some boxes because
that's easier to define and manage and
again no evil genius but the school
system the employment system all those
things have had a very specific track
yeah until recently no it was the the
wheels are stretching come on yeah and
so that's the part where I'm trying to
let you know that you're not alone that
the thing that's just below the surface
that you really feel about yourself or
that you want to explore but you haven't
you're not alone everyone's been you
know handed a bunch of shoulds
and to be totally Frank that should
never go away they change as you get
older but there's always going to be a
set of expectations and your job as a
human is to navigate that to be able to
develop tools to take what is helpful
and repel what is not helpful and manage
your own belief for yourself most of
this has to do with this cool thing that
I love which is intuition and your
self-awareness and when you can start to
pay attention to that that whisper you
know that's what I talk about being the
calling and I'm not saying as that that
whispered that's at eighth grade that
said you need it to be a a hippopotamus
veterinarian but mostly that there's
something in there and you don't have to
know exactly but you just know that
there's something that if you start to
pull on that thread great things happen
life starts to happen for you not to you
and that you start to be on a path and
when you're exploring this unfurling it
again this is to me where you everyone
has felt this everyone has felt that
time in their life that felt effortless
the one that you call it flow you're
with the right people doing the things
that you love and then you kind of go
okay great no we got to get practical we
got to get back to this is naive to
pursue this all these other messages and
again no evil genius this is just a
product of mass culture and being a
social species fine let's now develop
some tools to manage our way out of it
yeah and I think practicing those tools
becomes mission critical as a pathway
out because what happens is over time as
we age those intuitions and those
instincts become calcified as we settle
into this life that we think that we've
chosen for ourselves and that we work
double-time to convince ourselves are
good even if we're not happy totally
because this whole thing if I want to
change course now that's gonna up in
everything and my life is gonna turn
upside down and that's terrifying
yeah and I'm sympathetic to that oh no
I'd been in that situation you've been
in that's your version of that situation
and and and it becomes harder and harder
to connect with that little wisp that's
trying to speak to you because we've
constructed denial mechanisms around it
to prevent it from percolating up
because it is a reminder that
maybe we need to course-correct a little
bit yep and it's always there for us
that's the thing that why if you're in
that place of despair right now or
there's the big gap between where you
are and where you want to be because you
in and you know maybe you listen to this
right now going like damn like they got
me they figured me out you're not alone
and that to me just that little moment
of realizing that you're not alone
hopefully is enough to kick-start again
the way I frame it as a practice and a
practice is I think it's it's it's
intentionally called the practice
because sometimes it doesn't go well
right and and I don't want to paint a
picture I can go back to those books
that told you exactly how to do it you
know I take you on my journey too which
is like one of pitfalls and of near
death and of doing the wrong thing and
by wrong I mean not accordance with who
I was and my values and it's recoverable
the thing that we need to know as a
culture and what I'm trying to prescribe
is start and start small you don't have
to go from zero to a hundred miles an
hour in fact that's gonna make the
wheels come off we need to do is listen
and then start moving towards the thing
yeah and the call to action is that no
longer can you persist in this state of
creative repression to do so is to do so
at your peril and you open one of the
chapters with that great four name Brown
quote where she basically says like to
repress your creativity isn't benign
it's like it's an actually a dangerous
thing because you're living at odds with
your true makeup and that's gonna
provoke all kinds of damage in your life
in various ways so true and just look at
a culture that has repressed this key
thing a thing that differentiates us
from all the other species is our
ability to build tools and rocks and
create look a trout wherever you are
right now you're on a run I'm in your
ears listening to you know you're
running by the ocean everything that
park bench the car at the light post it
was all designed all created it was a
drawing before it was ever in real life
literally everything around you was
created and so if you start to think
about creativity in that sense
you start to say okay great you got my
attention now I'll pay attention to this
creative force that's supposedly I've
got this is you know chase and rich
telling me I've got this force you start
to pay attention to how valuable and how
important that force is and then think
of the messages that you get from
culture oh you know pursuing that
whimsical thing that you want to create
for your life that's just naive and
foolish the pursuing a career around
creativity playing the guitar
how much is you know starving artists
you hear others all these mythologies
that like Brene said when you repress
those that's your it's like literally
fundamentally your DNA to create mm-hmm
when you start to as simple as deny the
words like oh I'm not creative that is
really a toxic thought because it it
affects so many our areas of your life I
can't create my way into a good meal or
out of this relationship or into this
relationship or create a child or a
family or a if you start to think about
you're doing all of these actions and
you can acknowledge them rather than
impress them repress them there's an a
sense of agency that you gain and again
that's the Trojan horse of the book
right it's it's creating in these small
ways and recognize and acknowledging
them you know changing up the recipe
just a little bit to be a little more
like what you'd want it to taste like
mm-hmm
actually helps you see that you have
agency or your life
yeah and create fulfillment and purpose
for sure that's the that's the reason to
create right right right you're not
crying happiness for sure and then and I
think the that it is elusive and that we
have in our culture and that we have a
culture that doesn't really or as now
I'll say is on the cusp of actually
starting to acknowledge our creative
faculties you know that those things
coincide is like I get it mm-hmm
the fact that we're starting to
acknowledge it I think we're on the sort
of the cusp of a completely new era of
invention and reinvention and there's
plenty of things to be scared of and I
get all that stuff but just like the
Gutenberg press shifted literacy I think
we're on the cusp of shifting our focus
to creativity as
sort of the the complete reawakening of
our culture yeah as you've said many
times creativity is the new literacy
yeah
the best example that I've seen lately
of this brené Brown notion is the movie
in the book where'd you go Bernadette
have you seen this yet no oh my god you
got it first of all it's set in Seattle
no but it's just sink rinse all this
movie I thought it was wonderful but
basically a story you're getting I'm
thinking of my friend right now yeah
they're gonna listen to this and there's
we go I'm like dude I just think 20
lashes with a wet noodle from this guy
but basically it's a story of this
genius architect who then gets married
and has a family and spends the better
part of 15 years or so repressing her
creative impulses to the point of lunacy
like she starts to lose her mind and
it's the journey back towards
rediscovering what her essence is which
is to create and the idea of being like
she cannot be her best self or the
person that she wants to be unless she
is in the process of doing that and I
think that's a universal thing that
comes across in your book that this is
what it means to be human and we all
have our version of that yeah I'm
perfectly said that and I I don't want
to like invoke too much drama with the
like this is toxic because while I
believe that it's also recoverable like
we have you know we have a filter in our
spin on our bodies to take care of
toxins we also have a filter in our
heart and our soul too that knows what
it's supposed to feel like when things
aren't working and you know I say you
can look backwards and connect the dots
at the times when it felt right what
we're doing is we're actually trying to
sort of reconnect with that and what's
the new manifestation of it what is the
okay great whether it's you know what is
a daily practice look like for you all
you know connect the dots looking
backwards to what brought you joy at
some point in your in that that part of
your life what would you like to do
there's a book called play it away by a
guy named Charlie hone Charlie I know
Charlie yeah great author used to work
closely with Tim Ferriss just a lovely
human and
in his book play it away he literally
talks about finding time to play every
day and he talks in this in the book
about going he like bought up a
five-gallon bucket full of baseballs and
he and his buddy would go to the local
like park and one guy would pitch the
other guy and they'd just rope big
smiles all over the place and then walk
around and pick them up and it was just
such a joy and something he loved as a
kid and now he's doing it for 30 minutes
and an adult and it's just like
completely cracked him wide open right
and so it's not about the Perret and
moving to Paris that's simple things
like super simple things and they're
available immediately and that's the
cool thing like I'm not asking you to do
any of that crazy stuff moved to Paris
new set of friends anything it's like
right there right so you're on the
pre-med go to medical school track like
a mr. go back to the the timeline
narrative here that was the plan
and I relate to that that was my track
as well as pre-med for a couple years in
college before I lost interest in that
for reasons similar to your own you
discover this treasure trove of cameras
and then you proceeded to walk walk the
earth that'd be like cane yeah you go to
you go to Europe with your your then
girlfriend now wife you marry for a long
time now yeah I'll just wheat heart yeah
and this is where you start to really
deliberately explore creativity and
become this self-taught photographer you
know talk about that a little bit well I
don't know
again the just if you think about the
experience that I just went through as
my grandfather and hearkening back to
you know that's that moments of trauma
or fear or like a big change in life and
it doesn't have to be negative it can be
the birth of a child they cause us to
reflect and end up being really
convenient milestones or markers to like
whoa whoa whoa whoa what am i doing I
just don't want to have to wait for
those that's part of what the goal of
the book is like when we can we can be
awakened to that right now but just so
happens pain and trauma you know it's so
necessary it's like you know this thing
happened and then I realized that that
realization is available
to us but for some reason it's so
intangible unless we're triggered in a
certain way and you've had like this is
not the only I mean you've had like
three or four of these kinds of things
that have like helped you know sort of
reconfigure your trajectory yeah to get
back to your timeline though so I know
those things happened and and I did
manage to create some space for myself
to acknowledge that and and by that I
mean my creativity and just be a little
bit more thoughtful and it's important
for me to put a pin in this because the
space that I did give myself okay great
it was in Europe yeah
great sorry chase I can't get to Europe
I'm okay just to be clear I had to give
him been given a little money from my
grandfather and grant my grandmother
gave me some money for my grandfather's
passing and it was like a 13 stop ticket
right of half miles and 13 legs to get
to where I was going but it's not
required that it's Europe and it's not
required to be six months and and it
literally is available to you for me
this is what you know I decided to spend
my money eating beans and tuna fish and
sleeping on the ground in a sleeping bag
in order to just give a little space to
start to look inward because that's the
cool thing about all the biggest answers
in life we're chasing them out there I
want to be more like X or live the life
of Y or whatever the cool part and this
is why I keep saying it's always
available to you it's all in here it's
all intuition it's all what does the
speak does it speak to me and it you
know the interesting thing about a
calling and this is again not a psychic
calling to be a vet or whatever but it
starts out as a whisper and you get
better at listening to it and over the
course of days weeks months or sometimes
years you start to be able to listen to
that truth inside of you for you you
know you had a very clear experience of
hearing what changes you wanted to make
in your life and I had some version of
that as well and the people listening at
home whatever you were calling is it's
there you just need to sort of tune into
it yeah I would say I agree with that
but I would add that I'm not sure it was
so clear what
that little wispy sense of like this is
not right mmm like I kind of like that
thing over there and that's about as
clear as it was it wasn't like here's
what I'm gonna do here's the five-step
plan right you know sitting across a
table from Chase Jarvis like it was
nothing like that you know what it was a
tiniest faintest whisper of an instinct
and I liken that not to a map because a
map right would be like here's the red
dot here's all the dotted lines and then
here's the red X and you follow the map
and you get to where you're going if you
had the it's do that it would be the
equivalent of a map for me the whisper
that little thing the call is just over
there somewhere
that's what I think you used them just I
think I'm parroting and you said it's
that thing over there I'm saying that
that's a compass right and and so it's
not a map this is the both the cool and
the terrifying thing it's a compass a
map is reassuring because they can see
what it's good I can see the waterfall
and then I can see the bridge that I got
across and I think it's see the
saber-tooth tiger and but a compass is
like go that way
go toward the thing in very simple
imperfect terms you just start walking
and when you get to the top of the hill
then you can see oh my gosh there's a
giant crevasse I have to go around or
there's a bridge I might have to you
know jump across this thing in order to
get the thing and it's not knowing what
the path is going to bring that that
creates so much pause and inaction in
people and I get it I was the same way
like you're not alone but it is that
compass rather than the map and that is
that faint call that you walk toward I
use the metaphor of a path in the book
that starts to deliver it starts to like
make it clear that you're doing the
right thing you start to be around the
people you start to be closer to the
thing you can smell it you can feel it a
little bit it's still not clear and to
go back to yours it's not this like Gong
it's like something over there in the
bushes yeah I'm encouraging you to walk
to the bushes yeah I think predatory to
that though it's important that people's
compasses are properly calibrated I
think there's a lot of people out there
with
broken compasses for sure you know look
if you're [ __ ] up on drugs or you're
you know your priorities are out of
whack or you have some kind of
unresolved psychological thing going on
it's it's conceivable that your instinct
that thing that you might you might miss
identify a an instinct as being one of
those whispers and yet that's not
correct because you haven't done enough
internal work to be to be in a place
where you can trust that impulse yeah
and I think you you get burned by then
that impulse a couple times and it
strikes too easy it gets easy to turn it
off right the universe will give you the
message and this is what I advocate
that's like when you get there and it's
a false idol or it's the thing that you
thought it's not the thing that you
thought it was then you're like okay I
just walked all the way here for this
and then what do you do
you got check-in listen again and it
gets truer over time and that's the
willingness that's the fear that we all
have is that I just I walked toward
medical school I walked toward
professional soccer
I walked toward a PhD in philosophy none
of those things all of those things were
very expensive in cash and time and
emotion and none of them delivered and
yet in a weird way they all delivered
yeah they all informed what you do today
so they all had purpose and meaning but
they were all examples of you chasing a
life that was not your own but somebody
else's idea and the cool thing is after
you've done that a couple times you
start to realize okay that was expensive
no no what do I really want and then so
there's this sort of like the I think a
sensibility develops an honesty where
again go back that's why moments of
trauma and loss and joy extreme joy they
can be useful of course
because it'll pause you just enough to
go okay let's be real there's a an
episode I talk about in the book where I
basically should be dead by every every
measure I was
a horrible avalanche which is a very
scary thing it's sort of like getting
eaten by a shark you know it's not
awesome and for whatever reason I made
it out alive and that was also one of
those moments and having already had a
couple of them I was like hey do I
really need another one of these yeah I
mean that was gnarly
yeah reading about that yeah and I'm
again they're useful but wouldn't it be
better and what I've tried to do with
the book is like let's just pretend we
don't need those things that I don't
need that reminder totally let's try and
get get there without it yeah I think
it's also important to to underscore
that there might be this idea that your
mom or your dad were taskmaster saying
chase we want you to be a doctor or we
want you to be this and that's what kind
of propelled you onto that track but
that's not fair to them it doesn't I
mean I read an interview with your mom
and she sounded like it was it was like
on your blog it was like you know how to
raise a creative child and I got the
sense from her that she was very aware
that you were creative and was trying to
support that so it wasn't coming from
them necessarily it was more of a social
thing yeah and this is why it's
complicated right you know when your
career counselor is saying something and
it can be as subtle as do you think miss
Kelly was trying to complete throw a
spanner in my plans to be a comic artist
no way right but those are things that
we ascribe as young impressionable
social animals that when I talked about
earlier we talked about it's like what's
our toolkit now for managing that you
know you might have something going on
right now or your boss or your mentor or
whatever it's just really hammering on
it for one thing and just like is this
like what is the purpose of this what am
I supposed to take away from here and
and these are advanced tools right
especially as a young person you just
like oh geez my uncle says I should be a
you're just bouncing around totally and
and this is why this sort of small this
this pattern that I keep repeating is
this like a small creative acts on a
regular basis they start to inform
you remind you that you have agency and
so you the goal is to shift gears from
this sort of Cork in the tide to like
intention and then there's gonna be a
whole new set of challenges right you
can say wait a minute I've got a couple
of kids I got a mortgage I got it and
then that's a new set of obstacles that
you're all gonna you're you're gonna
have to manage and as you strengthen
these muscles and these tools to
navigate life to create your life things
again start to happen for you rather
than to you mm-hmm sometimes there's two
steps forward one step back to be clear
Oh most of the time you know improvise
it's it's about living your life with
intention and not living reactively yeah
right like take it like you said agency
it's really about having the mindfulness
and the presence of mind to be still
long enough to ponder what it is that
you really want and then take the
actions that set you on that trajectory
as opposed to just reacting to stimuli
around you or or being a people pleaser
and just trying to you know a sways the
people that you love totally and that
happens and it's it's easy to understand
why who wants to disappoint the people
that you love the most nobody does
nobody does yeah and yet what is
required to live the life that you want
you're gonna have to disappoint some
people because it's not their script
it's yours and yeah how many girls do
you get just to be clear how many goes
you get one so you know to put it in
perspective the number one regret of the
dying is that they lived somebody else's
prescription for their life
number one not number three or eight or
ten conveniently for this discussion
it's number one so if that's so that's
science that's that's the research says
like do we need other proof turns out we
do he did go red bump bump into a bunch
of stuff before we start to figure it
out I just want us to figure out as soon
as possible
rewrite the cultural narrative a little
bit about creativity and about what's
possible and get us to take action right
in terms of you developing your own
creative voice I mean you learned
photography pre-digital
we're not lame and not like you know not
in some kind of Scholastic setting you
were walking the earth and keeping a
juror
like FA you know 250 yeah
ISO whatever like trying to and then the
delay that comes with developing it and
then comparing it to your notes to try
to figure out like how do you actually
use a camera
totally and then remember when you
actually forget to record one exposure
and the other 18 after I enjoyed or what
I mean it's just like little small hairs
like that made learning so difficult but
but I've heard you say yeah it made you
pay attention like you had to be very in
you know like present for what you were
doing for sure and that's a wonderful
gift right and that's another thing that
happens when you actually care speaking
of lifelong learning it's not an
accident that I started creativeLIVE
which is a lifelong learning platform
like because I'm very passionate about
it and part of the way I develop that
passion was from seeing how hard it
could be mm-hmm
there's something interesting though
when something's hard that you really
want and that's why that honesty of like
this cut to brass tacks like what
matters it's it's it has this mechanism
of focusing your attention which I love
and to me that's cool you know when you
can actually latch onto something and
you can decide that this is something I
actually want to learn for me and had a
completely new definition of learning
like I was able to go through school and
like quote learn get decent grades and
you know do what I was supposed to do
check the boxes but it wasn't until like
deciding that I wanted to learn
photography that my mind went to it
completely different like I don't know
if any one I went to college and I
remember there would be like 29 year old
or 36 year old people in the class and
they would always have read all the
stuff they were super prepared and they
pissed me off so much like you're making
all of us look bad and it's because they
were there because they really really
really wanted to know about you know
ancient Greek mythology or whatever and
I was there because I was in school or
they're just brown nosers totally yeah
quite a possible outcome but the point
is when you know you start to to put a
lens of lifelong learning on something
that you actually care about is really
it's a cool way of looking at the world
and I think you you can unpack learning
in a different sense yeah
that's when the lights go on many I
don't want to say most but many
professional photographers of your of
your caliber malign the advent of
digital photography and the
democratization of this artform but you
all the way from the beginning have
celebrated it so I'm interested in how
you think about that as somebody who
learned in a very tactile analog way now
you just pick up your iphone you can
take 10,000 you know snaps of the same
thing and just pick the one that's good
and you don't really learn you're not
really learning about what you're doing
you're playing a game of chance and luck
as much as anything else so how do you
think about all of that well I think
about the process of learning slowly and
painfully and focusing your attention
largely in the way we just talked about
it's useful I it's true I did look at
digital photography as a mechanism to
subvert the pain that I had experienced
and as much as the technology at the
time was being debated like oh is this
gonna be as good or well you know it was
just like such a tired conversation two
weeks into having it when the first
digital cameras started to come out that
I was you know that I was able to sort
of see on the corner a little bit like
okay let's take this to its logical
connection or a large logical conclusion
that cameras gonna be really good is
whether it's two years from now or 10
years or whatever and that's what's this
thing called the Internet okay
information is gonna move and it's gonna
move a lot more quickly like I literally
had to go check out books from the
library on the history of photography
read them and then go take you know 36
exposures and then develop drop it off
at the place to be developed or develop
it in my bathroom my poor wife that I
turned into a darkroom
yeah like before you start breaking into
that darkroom I'll have to go there for
a second and look I'm a felon what's the
statute of limitations on oh I hope they
don't know I hope they don't come after
anyway go ahead and and so I selfishly
was like this is gonna accelerate
learning and I am gonna be able to take
picture and then look at the back of the
camera and immediately know is this good
bad or ugly and repeat and so the to me
it was an unlock and you got to remember
if you've made your life in this for the
previous 20 years and these new tools
start to come out that threaten your
existence and then quote anybody can be
a photographer would it create it was a
bunch of sort of acerbic grumpy
photographers and I chronicled this in
the book that there was like a new
school in the old school and it um my
end goal was just figuring it out mhm
and so because it was beneficial digital
was beneficial to me figuring it out and
I saw where the universe was going I
just like okay look it you can need to
put the brakes on her you can try and
lean into this and I just started
celebrating it which I turned out was it
turned out was very unpopular yeah time
and so I'm gonna I don't want to over
dramatize it but I literally had death
threats like you're taking money out of
my pocket you young punk and you put it
on the table of photographers who don't
deserve it and blah blah blah just from
sharing my experiences of trying to
master digital and and learn photography
in a way that other people hadn't
because the technology didn't it didn't
exist so I ended up never assisting
another photographer for day in my life
the first time I ever got paid for my
photography it was substantial I went
from like zero to making an income and I
realized oh my gosh this is actually
possible if I could do it once all I
need to do is like do it a couple more
times and then I've actually got a thing
and I think that that was a that both
gave me perspective and underscored a
really cool point that I think cements
in the book you know what nobody cares
how it got there anymore it's about
getting there and the cool thing we all
that there's a million paths to get to
wherever you are right now and your path
is just fine all the trauma that you
went through or that you didn't all of
the experience that you brought to the
table or that you didn't no one cares
you're at the table and or if someone
cares it's temporary and then
that's a yeah that will fade and so to
you know this is where impostor syndrome
comes from like I didn't earn and I
shouldn't be here
i as an example that my when I arrived
at my college which was you know that we
had lost in the national championship
the Division one national championship
the year before I I'm like how am I the
only freshman on a scholarship at the
number two school in the country for
Fattah our first soccer I'm clearly not
supposed to be here I'm here because
there was a guy who in the class ahead
of me was world class and they just
happened to see me when they saw him and
oh is this is a new younger kid coming
up and like I just told myself a whole
set of stories and why it's supposed to
be there but you know what there it was
you were there yeah and the same thing
played out in your your photography
career you did not you didn't you know
become an assistant to a famous
photographer like most people do you let
frog your way up you hustled and you got
a couple campaigns that you know
probably probably didn't predated like
your skill set at the time and you just
you you made it until you made it right
and and you were able to establish
yourself in a manner that was
unconventional for that field but I
think you know there's a couple
interesting things that happen in your
career which is which are timing related
in that you know you're you're starting
to develop your proficiency and your
professionalism and at a time when the
Internet is starting to profligate and
people are acclimating to this idea of
free flowing information and rather than
adhere to the paradigm of your
profession which is this is a black box
and we don't share our secrets and
that's how we you know maintain our
stranglehold on this profession right
you go the opposite direction
pre YouTube pre all of this stuff and
start telling the secrets you have the
trade which was not well-received at all
but ultimately gurnard you like you were
getting like a million readers on your
blog I remember stumbling upon your blog
around that time yeah and you were doing
something no one else was doing which is
basically taking people step by step
through your process as a means of
educating a whole
new crop of young aspiring photographers
which really set the stage or prefaced
what would come with creative life for
sure and you know what I was terrified
the whole time because I didn't do it
right I didn't do it the established way
I didn't do it and it was only you're
honest with all of that totally and that
is to me the cool thing because wherever
you are in your space right now
whoever's listening you're there you're
supposed to be that that was your path
and the cool thing is the worlds of
established paths and the paradigms on
how we get there and that there is only
one track that's largely being exploded
I would say to your benefit and if
you're looking at it from the
perspective of this is to my demise that
anyone can you're in the wrong headspace
well you're yeah you're you're you're
looking at the world through the lens of
a zero-sum game yeah and that's at odds
with
the premise of this book which is that
creativity is not only abundant it's
infinite and and to explore it just
creates more of it which is an abundant
perspective it's it's it's an abundant
mindset yeah and you know you
characterize it accurately I found
myself maybe before I was supposed to be
there at a place and I was like okay I
got there and all the while I was
battling the same head stuff that we all
do but somewhere in there was just
enough it was like one click above like
bravery had one click above shame and
and it was just enough to keep going and
I guess I'm living proof that that's all
you need right so now when you go on
YouTube I mean there's just a billion
instructional videos on every you know
the most detailed tiniest little aspects
of not just photography any geography is
the baseline but it's anything right but
when I when I like watch a Peter
MacKinnon video for example it's
impossible for me and I love what he's
doing I think he's brilliant and and
very engaging
but Peter McKinnon doesn't exist without
the example that Chase Jarvis set like
you created the foundation for the Peter
MacKinnon's of the world to be
able to do what they do well that's a
very it's a very large and very but it
was the seed you know it for sure
because it was it was before YouTube
even was I think that's true and even
like conceptualizing that is still like
oh geez I and I'm aware of it and you
know be like ah or even like but in a
prenup it's probably in a proud way not
a no-no toka but being also being
sponsored as a photographer that didn't
exist I brought sponsorship from action
sports where I was a photographer
watching athletes get free gear and then
start to be paid a living wage and I'm
like wait a minute why can't I apply
that here and I remember the first time
I started like pushing on this with the
camera manufacturers and they're like
and I'm like I see you know famous
photographer X on the back of a magazine
posing with a canon camera and then can
and would reach out or nikon and reach
out and say hey we see the work you do
and we loved it and I'm like okay cool
like they have yeah I'm willing to do
that it's like what do I get
oh you what do you mean what you get you
get to pose with a camera I back on a
thing and I'm like we're giving you a
totally and I'm like I get a
million-person are me over my shoulder
here I think I can actually make an
impact on what it is you're doing and
you know of course when anytime you're
ahead of the paradigm you're yeah I
think people start throwing rocks and
the you know without a need to unpack
all that the same as you mentioned about
just sharing what was in you know the
black box or whatever was unconventional
and it would become normalized over time
to me in a very positive way like
information wants to be free and and now
we take it for granted so it's really
hard to uncork that and look backwards
the same is true for mobile photography
like my industry through tons of rocks
at me when I was saying this one
megapixel camera was actually more
interesting than my hundred thousand
dollar digital Hasselblad right and you
know that was blasphemous completely
blasphemous and then I was like well
wait a minute instead of like fighting
over the same size pie let's make the
bigger pie with you know billions of
photographers rather than just twenty
million of us 20 in the corner trying to
protect a small thing that's going to
get out of the cage anyway
let's you know right and obviously again
not popular but to me that was just a
pattern that I continue to see unfolding
today in different areas of culture like
let's go there and let's blow this up
see if we could reinvent it in in
whatever image we want let's try it yeah
respect for this snapshot you know I
can't remember exactly what you said but
you put it really beautifully something
along the lines of you know we can all
appreciate the high art that is what is
created with that Hasselblad and a lot
of production value but let's not
overlook the beauty in the artistry and
the authenticity that comes with the you
know sort of downgraded snapshot of
everyday life taken by somebody who's
not a professional that there is
something truly valuable about that and
to the extent that now the internet is
making that widely available that's
something to be celebrated and respected
as a legitimate art form yeah rather
than the other way around and again what
is it
III hang on the Bezos quote because it
makes me feel better being willing to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
is sometimes required to make your way
in the world and and you know with all
these things that we're talking about
here in photography in particular um
we're using these as again this is sort
of a a metaphor but the same is true for
everybody in all their different areas
of life like I get I bet you were
misunderstood as a fill-in-the-blank
when you are in a band in high school
and you had long hair what you really
wanted was X and you're really getting
why and so again in the particular lies
the universal I'm talking about my story
right here but you know I want I believe
that everybody can see themselves in
this story that part being misunderstood
and starting to you know breaking
something open even if it was just your
relationship with your parents or or
whatever so yeah the the whether it's
sponsorship and photography or learning
you know teaching creativity on the
Internet
or getting people to value no doing a
gallery show where people can actually
value the snapshot that was a fun little
I did a show in the in the Ace Hotel
lobby where I invited 10,000
photographers from all the world to
submit images and I hung a fresh show
every day for 30 days using those images
and it was in you know and and it
attracted the curators from the Met and
the MoMA and they all came by to see
this thing because it was totally absurd
and yet really really cool and I
remember there's a woman who was the
curator at the Met at the time for a
photography Mia Fineman was her name
she's like oh I hear there's some really
famous photographers hanging and it was
true some of the best photographers in
the world that submitted images also
true dogs had submitted images right
five-year-old kids saw some images and I
hung them right next to each but that's
so beautifully subversive and and really
is your version of the people that
influenced you from Warhol the Basquiat
like these are people who you know
you've talked about this we're very meta
in making art about art in the way that
kind of Banksy is most famously doing
right now making a statement about the
art world through that kind of
expression yeah so it was a fun and that
you know my answer to her was she's like
I hear which can you point out some of
the and I was like you're the curator
from the Met why don't you tell me yes
and it was it actually started out nice
I'm sure that got a scowl from it was it
actually was a little bit of a light
bulb and it it actually created a
friendship we had lunch that's the
conversation tone right yeah yeah and it
just underscores the point of like it
doesn't matter how they got there they
were there mm-hmm and which is true for
all of us like I don't know you got to
where you are in this case you're the
arbiter you're making the decision about
what's going up and what's not but but
it begs the question of like who gets to
make the decision about what is art and
what isn't yeah yeah and you know if you
tie it back to you know the themes that
were exploring here in the book it's
like it doesn't matter how you got there
you know just claim claim who
you are where you are what you are and
move forward right so you sell your
first photo 94 I think you're working in
a you know in the ski shop you've done
your research NAFTA snapped an awesome
photo
for 500 bucks and pair of skis and this
it you know fast forwarding all the way
to you know commanding massive budgets
and shooting with you know fortune 100
companies Nike you know everybody
basically Red Bull
Apple Apple yeah we want to talk about
that too
one of the things that that is kind of a
hallmark of how you established your
career was to really value yourself
right and I think we're in this
disposable economy now where I don't
think creativity is adequately let alone
financially appreciated we think that
well he took a picture I should be able
to use it wherever I want however I want
and and we don't think of the inherent
value of of what's entailed here and
you're somebody who's always you know
been very deliberate and making sure
that you establish your own value and
and used your experience as a voice
piece to encourage other people to do
the same and so the question I have
about that is how do you square that
with kind of the the garyvee message of
just go out there and like do a ton of
stuff for free like say yes to
everything you know get in with you know
people who can advance your career and
just be a team player like I think
there's wisdom in both of those but
somehow you got to find a mix that works
where you're still valuing your input
while also trying to build your pedigree
free or cheap forever never in between
yeah like having the Seth Godin thing
yeah what he always says about public
speaking it's either full fare free
great I didn't know a set that said that
he's a dear friend I was just talking to
me the other day great guy we're gonna
do a thing in New York together on 24th
when the book drops yeah free or full
price and I think free is fine because
free gets you portfolio connections
experience
um and those are valuable things but
what's the worst is like hey what's your
rate $5,000
I have 80 bucks okay that's the worst
because then you've you know you've then
taken what you've posted as your value
and burned it versus saying I'm gonna do
this because I'm gonna get something out
of it and here's my requirement I will
make the creative decisions and if you
don't like it you can't use it or
whatever the paradigm that you establish
for your work is so I think they're
reconcilable I don't think it's either
you know value yourself or don't I think
it's okay to find other aspects of value
to place on you and your work besides
money yeah I think what happens with a
lot of young people is they they they do
end up you know doing a lot of free
stuff as they should as they're learning
but they don't then also learn the skill
of of knowing when to say okay now it's
the time yeah hey me or they start at
these very micro amounts and they're
afraid they don't want to alienate
anybody or or like piss anyone off and
so they end up toiling you know in this
netherworld where where the work isn't
getting valued even though the quality
of it is is would substantiate that
totally true and that is a learned skill
and the only way you learn is through
practice and this is why I advocate
action over intellect like if you're
sitting around trying to figure this out
and make the perfect chess move like
that's not how it happens you make a lot
of little imperfect moves you learn a
little bit of a lesson and then you move
on just trying to make the same mistake
more than you know one or two times I do
leave one but it's the action it's the
doing that actually creates the learning
it's very hard to and it's it's great to
get information from the internet or
your mentor or whomever but learning
like actually doing that part is
incredibly valuable so you know again I
think it is reconcilable the you can
still value yourself and you can still
work for free and I do believe in
connections and
and I would you know choose to use the
word community you're building a
community of people who are there to
teach you to learn from you to be
supportive and for you to support and
that's all valuable I think that's
something that's wildly overlooked in
you know talk about it specifically a
section of your book that's a quarter of
the book is about the benefits of
community and how it's widely overlooked
as key to the success in anything even
if it's a solo artist or whatever like
whole sorry as a whole slew of people
who make this possible this experience
you have created possible so and and I'd
you know to keep that thread and maybe
put put a period at the end of it I
think it's reconcilable I think that
experience is the only way you can
navigate it and I understand why you'd
want to think about it before you
entered it which I encourage you to do
but in the end you can't actually be
paralyzed if you're just so precious
that you're not willing to do anything
for free and you're getting no work that
should be something that should be
assigned yeah yeah yeah in any and
extrapolate this to away from
photography to anything that you want to
move into that's the that's the big
conundrum right is like how do I start
something in a worldwide I have no
experience
alright that's whether it's get a job or
shift gears or you want to go move to a
new career or like how do I start when
no one will hire me yeah I think that
the this subjective preciousness is one
that that doesn't get enough attention
or discourse like when you don't have a
tremendous amount of experience but
you're overly Precious about what you're
doing and you tend to overvalue yourself
and you missed up right because you're
not you're not you're not objectively
judging the the business landscape yeah
and and one of the things you talk about
in the book is like not being pretty
like just just make the next thing just
keep moving on just keep moving on like
I have a friend he's this very
successful screenwriter and his whole
thing is like as soon as you finish a
script like it's very easy you know
we're in Hollywood here I know a lot of
people that are in this world like they
get they're so precious about their
thing and they can't move on to the next
thing and they're just waiting to hear
if it sells or
they get very caught up in all these
externalities that they have no control
over
so his thing is like you just
immediately start the next thing so
you're immersed in the next creative
project and you're divorcing yourself
very mindfully and purposefully from the
results of your creative output yep
the judgment ends up being a really
toxic a spective of any creative output
and I do mean creative with the capital
C like you know we start to judge too
soon
Warhol had a great like when everyone
else is busy judging your work you go
back to making the next thing right
right let them judge it yeah yeah well
on the subject of community building I
want to get to that because that that is
kind of an exclamation point in this
second act break that is the Chase
Jarvis movie you basically realize all
of your dreams you go from this
fledgling you know photographer working
in a ski shop to working with these huge
brands and and like I said earlier
commanding these huge budgets and you
know like helicopters and the you know
the craziest stuff you can imagine like
this is your dream realize like you have
everything that you ever aspired to to
have you are as successful probably
beyond what you could have ever
predicted for yourself a way way in and
then it took this other tragedy which
you you touched on this Avalanche to
really recalibrate how it was that you
were living so maybe dig a little bit
deeper into that what what I've come to
know is that I feel like there's two
arcs in a life there's an arc where
you're accumulating wisdom knowledge
friends connections perspectives and at
some point most of us know not what or
when there is a shift I think this is
really a beautiful shift if it's
possible to like okay I have enough my
fear since my my biology I can override
my biology and start to think in terms
beyond just me and that is one thing as
a weather and you know parents probably
understand that or people who used to be
a one-woman shop and now
you have many employees or like whatever
the analogy or the experience is there's
a some part you're like wait a minute
and again we can choose that or things
in life can choose it for us and if
you're sort of ignoring it then you're
going to get a lesson and my lesson was
as it turns out this Avalanche and
despite living as you said the the what
I had carved out is my dream it's sort
of like as soon as you have something
when you don't have anything you got
nothing to lose and then when you have
something you have everything to lose
you have a life you have community you
have resources money reputation all
these things and so this sort of fear
instinct survival mechanism biology what
I'm going to call it kicks in and then
you stay in that mode versus this sort
of open mode that I'm you know trying to
be in and just being aware of our own
mortality and creativity and all this
stuff and so in my universe I got cotton
is bad avalanche and mmm somehow got out
and I remember didn't sleep maybe like
15 minutes the next night or that that
night and it was about just like really
calling everything into question and it
sounds a little bit too movie script II
but like straight up that's how when I
own and I I just did an interview with
on my podcast with a guy named Ben who
was one of the Nike athletes that I was
actually filming when it happened oh
well no one was hurt by the way right
correct everybody got out yeah yeah
minor minor everyone everybody got away
and um Alaska yeah was mass I'm talking
like entire Mountain face ripped off
like enough snow to fill up multiple
football fields 50 feet deep like
there's not a thing you walk away from
and I remember talking to Ben and we
literally never talked about it like
when I was reunited with the rest of the
athletes and the guides and stuff at the
bottom we just flew off and like shut
you know is there is skiing and
Uncharted stuff in Alaska this is like
where all the the films that you see are
made and all the best advertisements and
whatnot and we like we there's it
actually we have the moment of me being
caught in the
that's on film and then the person who's
filming that like they go oh [ __ ] and
they drop the camera and they run and
it's it's very dramatic scene and then
the next piece of footage is the person
goes and picks up the camera and you
know this is some time later because I
whatever escaped and and then I'm
reunited with the group and I ski up to
the group and the camera is running on
me and they just say whoa and I'm like
do not tell my wife about that just
right but that is literally the extent
that we talked about it right well in
the moment it's so it was so
overwhelming that you have to minimize
it totally yeah and so fast-forward to
that night and honestly the next several
weeks but that night in particular like
what am i doing
it's sort of like as soon as you you get
there you think that you're it's like a
false summit you see a summit if you're
a climber you [ __ ] okay cool and you
crest the mountain and you're like only
to realize that this is the first summit
and there's a whole nother mountain
behind that and to me that was decided
to try and paint a bigger picture of
what was possible for my experience and
that was trying to help other people I
had just been given so many gifts or
earned so many gifts through that
journey that I'd been on that was like
wow this is a thing like what if we
could like reproduce this and give this
gift to other people what's the you know
the message so I that that is in part
what inspired me to do the iPhone half
the right that was the first iPhone app
that shared photos to social networks it
was like I started creating tools and
platforms for other people to try and
tap into what I had had the chance of
experiencing I mean it wasn't it wasn't
a complete departure because I've had
been sharing you've been blogging been
transparent about this journey all along
but it was more an epiphany about how to
contribute its scale yeah right so you
create you got it all this story you
create this iPhone app oh that's a
camera I know it's painful dude a lot of
people haven't heard at best camera
predates Instagram but in many ways
extremely similar to the earlier
versions of Instagram you upload
photo there's filters a whole squirt you
could scroll through all the filters at
the bottom we created all I mean it was
yeah
it becomes the it becomes the app of the
year it's getting written about on all
the tech blogs near the New York time
this covers it this is what you know the
people who work at Apple are using and
your position Steve Jobs Hill are all
those people quoting and talking about
it they use the the name of the app was
best camera right after a phrase that
popularized the best camera is the one
that's with you
Apple start I have a trademark that
Apple starts using it in their people I
mean I've heard of the modern vernacular
now a lot of people say you know the
best camera is the one that some version
of babe Meyer and you have never
enforced it be careful
go ahead no you tell the story why am i
telling the story because you're it's I
love hearing it through your experience
you got it right a that I think there's
no artist version is just created the
the first app that allowed you to take a
picture add a cool effect that we call
filters which is a term from photography
and it was the same thing we basically
decided that I want to be cool if there
was like a set of filters at the bottom
of the app that was loosely based on the
dock concept of an apple operating
system that didn't exist used to meet
like a tile across all some of the other
apps had and of course now it's
ubiquitous yeah totally and but the day
and everything has a yeah as an origin
and then you could just you know press
one button and submit it to as many
social networks that you wanted at one
time or there was a community at the
best camera which was the first photo
feed but like the live photo feed in an
app and then just for contacts like I
remember when I originally submitted it
you know Apple was interesting as
interested in in the app and I was
developing it and they knew about it and
I had done I hadn't launched some
products for them I'd done some work in
the photography universe can't really
talk about it because we could get
sniper at some time if I talked about it
but and so they knew about this app and
they said no you can't do this what do
you mean you can't just like well we
can't have a photo fee the concept of
just photos that you post and then are
in a feed that's just not something that
we can do
because you know we can't validate the
image or you know might violate
community or you know our policies or
whatnot so I had like this is how early
it was had to work with them to
literally validate the concept of a feed
of photos Wow without yeah and and again
this is something people understand how
it wasn't all that long ago yeah you
know because it's so ubiquitous now but
yes 2009 2009 yes yeah
so the to cut to the chase bum bump bump
put the thing out in September that year
it went straight to number one within a
matter of days and lived there for a
long time as you mentioned we came out
for the year and through a handful of
weird what I would call esoteric
mistakes or missteps that were in the
contract some of it was with I had an
external partner developed the app I
told them what I wanted they built it we
massaged it and and in that era it was
really hard to have an account that
would allow you to submit software to
the App Store even getting the account
you didn't know how long it would take
would be be validated what you know is
like it was a black box also because it
was just so new and there were still
hundreds of thousands of apps but so
rather than me having my own account I
just used the developers account and
come to find out that that actually
means that so even though contractually
I own the code that wasn't work for hire
if I can't touch the code I can't move
the code I don't have access to the code
once it's on their account it can't be
transferred over right and now they're
all those things are transferable but
none of yot was true so we had an app
sorry that we had a contract that
stipulated that there would be 13 I
think it was 13 new releases over the
course the next year one right away if
we found bugs or whatever and then one a
month for the next year because we
thought that that's how long it was
gonna take to they developed the app for
free on the back end of it was a 70/30
revenue split and then when they had
been paid back it would flip 70/30 to me
well we had figured out that was gonna
take about a year on average to pay us
back and we were paid back in six days
mm-hmm or they were paid back in six
days and then when that revenue share
flipped when then suddenly they're only
getting thirty their dissolve right
yeah their desire to and it's important
like it's still like it seems now
looking through the lens of 2019 well
there's still a lot of money to be made
at 30% but back then that's not the
perception of apps these things come and
go yeah they have a very short shelf
life you just it's a cash grab and you
move on yeah and that was the baratunde
I'm sitting there saying no you don't
get it these are gonna be huge
multi-billion dollar companies this is
the future of software development it's
decentralized in blah blah blah blah
blah and of course it falls on deaf ears
so in about that time when the app is
now sort of its full-blown just peaking
and starting to crest and there's not a
lot of updates coming up because rather
than you know to add a friend and follow
geography and all the think the things
that we get backed out together
you can't like predict what's gonna be
in a software released nine months from
now and that'd be a bad contractor right
because you're locked in so they would
do things like release it in French that
was what how they got they managed to
navigate the Contra right so they were
still in alignment with the contract but
not the spirit for sure and without
going into the weeds any further than
we've already gone that obviously
creates a space when you're not
innovating anymore and despite your the
you're the number one app in the App
Store that creates a place so called
bourbon yeah there's a guy called kevin
kevin says holed up in an office in San
Francisco doing what you've created yeah
and there used to be a video on the
internet while Robert Scoble was
interviewing him and say isn't this just
best camera is it go yeah well we've
looked at you know a lot of the apps and
and obviously Kevin's an amazing
business person yeah created a billion
dollar company in just a matter of
months short story long it is
they threw 50 million bucks at it
supplants at it and you know just
started innovating and and doing great
work and meanwhile I didn't have access
to the code
I was roughly speaking paralyzed both
conceptually and I didn't have any way
of of managing code that I couldn't put
my fingers on and we just got smoked mmm
and then of course when the when
Instagram sells for a billion dollars a
year later you know let's just say my
phone was ringing yeah
wrote about and that was a challenging
oh here it is yeah it honestly it took
me and and I was off Instagram for then
I think almost five years right
just because my lawyers wanted to
preserve the right to sue because I was
damaged and you know I just got caught
it up can't establish damages if you're
here on Instagram yeah and it's just
like lawyer stuff and at some point I
was just like this is honestly so after
a lot of litigation I actually did get
the code back after like number of years
and the company was purchased by
Deloitte part way through this process
that I had contracted so then it wasn't
just me against the tether contractor it
was like me against delight which
unpleasant so you know again so you
couldn't even do any kind of exit out of
that no it's just I got a zero right
that's a well and to be fair there like
there there's another chapter which is
not well documented this is stories very
well documented yeah yeah very long blog
post about it an idio all that get up in
the show and the the and it's in the
book yeah
what's I did get the code back and I did
sort of like throw some cycles at it and
and revived it and I did have an
opportunity to sell it to some other
companies but at that point it was just
like it was still like never work again
money but my ego was so smashed and my
soul was like no I think I'd rather take
it's sort of like for your full price
taking my own advice which I would
regret now it would be nice to not have
to work but I just leveraged everything
that I learned in that experience from
not having venture capital being
accountant table of one and a team of
just a small hard-working team that I'll
never forget at my photo studio who
really put the judge into this and just
leverage it in a creative life so I
learned a lot of lessons along the way
yeah I mean it all went into the hopper
and goes back to the Domino's all lining
up like it would creativeLIVE had
occurred well listen though you become
Instagram there's well I can you're done
but it provided the fuel and the
experience that birthed this amazing
platform yeah you're now and running so
tell tell people what creative live is
for those that doesn't sure happy to do
it creatively
I've is a platform largest platform
focused specifically for creators and
entrepreneurs it's where you know 10
million people have gone to learn
photography design filmmaking
entrepreneurship it has the you know
pill it surprise winner is New York
Times bestsellers the best of the budget
each best of the best in each of those
disciplines and there's we've given way
billions and billions of minutes of free
video there's always something free
playing you can go learn about any of
those things from those types of people
and there's also a subscription and if
you want to buy an individual class you
can go there to learn so it was yeah it
definitely came out of the ashes of my
my best camera experience and today is
you know it's it affects way more people
then then best camera ever did not
unfortunately Instagram but now it's you
know it we're basically a decade in now
and and it's cool it's cool I've gotten
I've gotten a lot out of it personally
just to be on the journey and I love to
see that it's impacted a lot of people
and that's the part that I wish I could
share and I wish I could package it up
and put it in the book and I struggled I
tried a bunch of different ways to you
know in part that's what made me want to
write the book honestly because you know
I think about being this second grader
and being told that I wasn't really
shouldn't pay attention as creativity
stuff and then figuring it out in a very
imperfect messy crappy way and then
starting to acknowledge that creativity
building a living in a life for myself
then starting bisque and becoming the
creator that I was denied I look at that
as as refusing to betray myself so
acknowledging that then starting to
develop tools for creators like the
iPhone app well first of all I guess the
the community around creativity in the
photography community and then tools
like the iPhone app and then platform
for learning you can see this like
progression a little bit and you know
now there's a platform there and what
was missing in all this is the why like
why is this valuable is it just for
photographers is it and that was what
has been sort of lingering for me for 10
years
wait a minute I have come to know
creativity as this ubiquitous incredibly
powerful force arguably like creativity
and love or the things that are that are
human being superpowers and yet there's
a you know we can talk about love and I
think if I say love is a superpower of
human beings no one goes like mmm here
we go yeah I guess right and yet
creativity has been sort of left out of
that conversation so for me you know
writing the book was a little bit about
I need to sort of put my arms are in
this whole process it's the best work
I've ever done and it's in a package
that I didn't want to write a book I'll
just I wanted to make an internet video
and call it good but it wasn't the right
format how did it come about then in a
very reluctant manner yeah I am a visual
artist I am fast at that and it's
natural to me and I have written a
thousand blog posts on my blog I've you
know in graduate school yeah you're a
graduate I mean you're a graduate
student in philosophy you're how
stranger to writing sure but when he
comes to it comes to deciding to write a
book it was I was an unwilling unwitting
author but I knew it had to be a book
because of the the the potential of the
vehicle it's the right package to get
into popular culture because you know if
there are people who identify as
creators who are listening to this
they're like right on dude like this is
representing my tribe my identity I get
it go there's a whole other
cross-section of the universe that I
call creative curious people who are
like stringent like I'm there's no way
I'm not creative I don't want to be I
don't want art I want fill in the blank
I don't know what you want if you don't
want that but there's a huge population
of people who I think can their lives
can be transformed and even for the
creators like if you start to get out of
that creativity the small see like art
and you get into like oh wow this is
actually an architecture for life that
needed to be in a book that's not an
Internet video yeah and so I haven't
this is a great creative horizon for you
though right is a tackle something like
this is new totally and it was my own
medicine big time yeah like you just
rely on on the book that you were
writing that was not yet
they were to write the book so many
times I literally had to kagetora Boris
knew I had to go back like I just see
page 37 or see this sticky note on the
corner of my desk that I wrote a year
ago right that said this one thing yeah
god I gotta take my own advice so it was
both a beautiful incredibly painful but
also beautiful experience to feel the
process actually work yeah and it was a
little bit of a litmus test while you're
doing it's sort of like doing your
subtraction to check your addition or
whatever like writing a book about
creativity and being neck deep in it and
having to just continually extract
yourself go look at the rules that you'd
set out in the previous chapter follow
them and and that it worked I think is
in part a testament but it was also
really humbling and I think that's you
know I've talked a lot in this you know
conversation about the cultural shoulds
and inputs from all the people that you
love and and learning to navigate those
it's also really important to know that
a those not never go away
but nor do a lot of the fears around
creativity and the struggles and that it
never becomes just this easy greasy path
which I hope it doesn't turn anyone off
because that's where the best so I think
it's super important to point that out
somebody who's who is as creatively
productive as you are to acknowledge
that you still struggle with that I
think gives people encouragement and
permission to feel like they're they can
then be included good well yeah I lived
it yeah that's what these dark circles
under my eyes are from and there's that
torture between when you know you send
it off to the publisher and when you get
to start talking about it and I'm you
know so I'm over the moon to be sharing
this with you and your community here
long appreciated it and you know we've
had a lot of inspiring discussions
you've been on my show and like I just
love the approach and to be able to be
unlike right now I'm using my own
medicine to to be creating the the first
experience or the first impressionist
book on the world so right also clearly
struggling looking for words not knowing
I'm talking
but I mean I think you said it all in
the book and I think it's beautiful and
another another aspect of it that I want
to address is another another myth of
conventional wisdom which is that
creativity and financial well-being are
mutually exclusive like a huge part of
your adventure isn't just becoming
creatively literate it's becoming a
successful businessperson and
entrepreneur and learning how to grow
into this idea that these two worlds can
are not mutually exclusive and can
coincide and and support each other
mmm and I will get an endless array of
[ __ ] for putting those two sentences or
those two words in the same book
creativity and money and that's you know
going but they don't they can't exist
without each other
bingo okay so this is you open with some
of the your favorite books you know the
war of art artists way like be damned if
they talk about sort of money and those
things because it's so pure its art and
to me that was the thing that I needed
to put in the book was this there's one
section called the big three and one of
the big three is that is that is money
and it either comes in in like oh you
need some money to get started or you at
some point if you do this someone will
say I like your work or and you just
have to have an opinion on it and I'm
I'm part of the mission is to dispel
this idea this toxic myth that the
starving artist which as it turns out
just comes back from this you know the
period in the early part of the last
century where these French people were
hanging out
it's basically love oh hem the musical
you get Simone de Beauvoir and jean-paul
Sartre hanging out at this cafe Ladue
meh go and they starving artists they
hang pride on this because it's how they
identify and and just comes to find out
it's a really toxic myth because it's
the reason that so many of us are not
hearing how powerful creativity is until
now because there is a myth of the
starving artists and who wants to pursue
our
you realize you're gonna starve and
sadly it's stuck right it's this is a
powerful vision that we are narrative
based creatures you know we learn
through story and that sad toxic story
has been you know responsible for
uncorking many a creative life because
of the woods and the sheds and the and
understandably like do your parents want
you to be starving know if they hear
this myth they and I'm oversimplifying
it but the reality is that creativity
and money creativity is also you can
tell this to whoever's telling you
otherwise it is the it is a vehicle for
creating the most impressive you know
opportunities for access to wealth that
the world knows the same we were just
you know joking about Kevin Systrom and
Instagram
dude created a billion dollar company
they had either nine or 13 people in it
right and hit it in two years it's
insane
so you know and that's a while the
creative experience that they went
through in order to pull that off so I'd
like to marry those things in an
unpleasant messy way and just you know
we can talk about it but that's they
they do have to be in relationship to
one another if you're gonna move through
an actual life yeah art doesn't exist
without Commerce and and with that there
is there is a healthy tension also
because you know look if you look at the
movie business like there's the artistic
vision of the filmmakers and there's
what the marketplace will tolerate and
those to the the tension that exists
between those two things sometimes
produces a work of great genius
depending upon the people involved or it
craters the whole thing turns it into a
disaster you know and and you never know
what you're gonna get nobody goes into
making a movie thinking they're gonna
make a bad movie totally but how you
balance that tension and navigate the
vicissitudes of Commerce with respect to
how it informs or does not inform our
ultimately is you know an essential
discussion and component of any of any
creation so true and I like that little
move that you made there at the end of
that phrase was like at any creation
because yeah we're talking about art and
commerce but the same thing is true with
life right when you're creating
something you can create it money can be
part of what you desire because you're
trying to create the ability to sustain
the thing you're doing and there's
nothing wrong with that
whether that's baking a cake making a
family writing code whatever the thing
that you're doing whatever you're
engaged in and that should be okay yeah
like money is not a dirty word money you
know facilitates especially if you can
do some good things with that
yeah but we're so afraid to bring it up
and hope yeah again that's like I'm
trying the same thing with creativity
like you just picture the beret the
cigarette disease the painting is not
the time that's not what I'm talking
about at all sure it'll supercharge
those things if that's what you're into
and and I hope that folks who identify
as that or with that will get a ton of
value but I'm trying to make this like
more accessible draw a bigger pie put
arms on a bigger population and include
these things and have historically been
like no I didn't just say the n-word any
yeah yeah and let's do let's deconstruct
that wall of fear that is preventing you
from trying something new and the truth
is all of those excuses are now of no
merit in a time and a day when almost
everybody has a smartphone in their
pocket so whether it's photography or
writing or filmmaking like you have a 4k
camera like I made a short film that did
the the festival circuit back in 2005 we
shot on 35 film and the process of
post-production to get it into like
1080p was the most ridiculous Pro try I
had to go to this fancy post house and
it was like teams of people working on
all this kind of thing now you have 4k
in your pocket and an editing app that
you can use to make a movie and Steven
Soderbergh
is making features you know high-quality
features with movie stars with his
iPhone yeah those excuses are gone bingo
so now we're confronted with
ourselves it's just right when you're
surrounded by these yeah yeah you know
and to me that's another thing if you go
back too early in a conversation that
I'd love is it's almost it's you have to
avoid it if you right if you really
don't want it you have to try you know
you have to run away quickly from this
right and and now I like to tell a story
of my mom who when I did that happen mm
I think she was 65 at the time and you
know you mentioned earlier she was an
administrator a biotech I was raised
sort of middle lower middle class and
and yet still hadn't you know that I had
I was never never wanted for much and
yet she's always very precise and like
also very frugal the heat never got
above like 58 you were cold put on a
sweater uh-huh and and she took right
and that was very practical and because
of that had not thought of herself as
creative and really didn't care and when
I did that I phone app and I got her an
iPhone but that $3 app in her hand in no
extra time is she didn't have to go buy
a set of paints she didn't have to go to
the art supply store didn't have to take
a woodworking class or she didn't have
to like get a new set of friends she
just started using the phone when she
would take her daily walk and start
taking pictures at an effect and share
it with your friends she would
occasionally post to a social network
and I watched her both recognize her own
creativity this is not it over months
either this is like minutes not days
it's somewhere like weeks recognize your
own creativity it almost was like
confronted with it cuz it was so obvious
and her friends like oh my god joy
you're so creative and I watched it
change how she approached cooking I
watched it change how she dressed i
watch it changed the kinds of vacations
she wanted to take she wanted to go
explore just from learning that she was
creative by taking pictures every day
with her phone no extra time this was on
a walk that she did every day and it was
transformative and so I think that's
like again you have these tools or now
are all around us right
to publish and to avoid the gatekeepers
and all of the things that we used to
have to think really clearly I'd like
now you really have to try and avoid it
so to the person who's listening to this
and you are avoiding it what are you
scared of ask yourself the question and
the ability to step into that fear is a
pretty low barrier and I think there
might be if you're anything like my mom
or a lot of other people who've picked
this up like the the barrier is so low
you can trip over it yeah like give it a
shot and I think you'll be surprised and
I think you'll be you'll find yourself
empowered to I think and on the subject
of you know creativity being the new
literacy I think that's a sensibility
that is second nature to Generation Z
that's coming up who are born and raised
with these tools they've never known a
world without light it's very different
and they're pursuing lives that are
premise taun creativity in a way that
was not accessible to you and I'm a
little bit older than you but you know
just wasn't even part of the
conversation when we were young people
and I think it's really gonna be cool to
see what that produces ten years twenty
years down the line so truth people that
that their their literacy is creativity
like it's it's it's just so hardwired
into them that the idea of not being
creative or not being a creative person
is something that wouldn't even occur to
them right in words matter like that's
one of the things that I talk about in
the book that I think escapes people
sometimes like when you say oh I'm not
very creative like a little damaged
there hmm and you know go back to the
burn a quote that you mentioned and and
what I'm encouraged by is when you've
grown up with these tools and or if you
haven't grown up with them but you're
willing to step into them and encourage
your incur a little bit of fear you'll
find that the the the barrier is so
small you just step over that thing and
then you can start start creating that
I'm encouraged by that and honestly
that's one of the reasons that I I had
to do the book it was just like like oh
my god it's happening it's happening the
thing I've been thinking about
for virtually my entire adult life and
happened to me and I'm like gosh and so
you know that's what ultimately I I
called it my eighth grade book report I
my agent is like yeah you got to do the
book you can decide and I'm like yeah
and then one day I was like I took a
weekend I wrote when I lovingly refer to
my eighth grade book report and was
literally like 10 pages sent it to my
agent Steve and he was like this is it
mm-hmm and then we were off - so in
other words saying this is my 8th grade
book report was a way of lowering the
stakes for you so it didn't seem so
total imitating yeah and I just again I
just did the work as I was afraid you
know there's a lot of you start to see
culture moving in the direction that
you're talking about as I had a couple
that's my gift right is to be able to
see around the corner and some some
technologies or culture and I was like
oh my god it's like happening again and
like let's change the vehicle if it was
an app or if it was a platformer I was
like let's that's why a book had to I
had to write a book but what a cool time
that's part of like what needs to be the
takeaway from this talk is whether you
are all in on this or you're just
deciding if you're gonna put your toe in
the water amazing time and it just so
happens that this corresponds with it is
the riskiest time in the world to play
it safe because whatever you were sold
as safe
now that's beige it's vanilla it is you
you it's not like you'll blend in in a
good way
it's you're leaving so much on the table
in terms of identity earning power
connection with other people
vulnerability authenticity like if
you're not sort of participant of not
participate yeah especially as we we
progress towards this AI you know
society that is gonna commandeer a lot
of those jobs sure and then just listen
to Jack Ma who's the founder of Alibaba
which arguably the most data centric one
of the most data centric companies in
the world that retails basically like
super retail in China
whatever mega mega company his kids if
you give a speech at the world I can
oh my kids no no they're not worried
about coding
no no that's computers are coding and
computers are teaching other computers
to code my kids creativity painting
connection sports human movement
everything that machines are not and if
that's not a clue from the guy who
basically wrote mapped the future of a
eye and you know all that kind of stuff
like wake up call right and again you
can look at that as fear or let's flip
the script and say what a cool time to
experiment what a cool time to try a
thing that I haven't done before
and you know go back to as I mentioned a
second ago the the line that you bought
as a young person where we were fed or
sold or whatever the mechanism were
transaction it it truly is risky not in
the sense of only in economic prosperity
but as in leaving your like who you are
on the you know back on the desk like
that is yeah that would be a very heavy
price to pay to not be able to express
yourself in the way that you were
capable of and to to leave with that on
the shelf over there and it robs you of
that opportunity to be more fulfilled
and to live a more Purpose Driven Life I
mean if there is a theme to this show
that I do it's it's how can we live more
authentically how can we you know create
a life for ourselves that is more in
tune with our natural blueprint and
that's a journey of discovery that will
last you your entire life but the more
that you can kind of connect with that
and explore that not at the behest of
leaving your job necessarily but just to
bring more of that experience into your
life I think will guard it with meaning
and will lead you on an incredible you
know journey of discovery of yourself
and I think will brighten the the palate
of the world yeah so well said I'm gonna
use that we comin through remedies I
know but that's the subhead you know the
book is like establishing any practice
in future world of meaning because
that's what this does and just so
happens that this helps you like fine
that's something as talented as you are
behind the lens I really do think your
your your superpower is being able to
see around the bend and when you look
back on these pivotal moments in your
life and these decisions that you've
made you've always been just a little
bit ahead
you know like at times maybe a little
bit too early but always preface in what
ultimately comes and we're seeing this
now with with creative live I mean
creative lives been around a decade that
got long that means crazy and now you
can't watch a YouTube video without
seeing an ad for master class like it's
a crowded space now yet people are
moving in there's a lot of high quality
stuff going on but you were a first
mover here I don't know if you were the
first but you're the first to really
truly establish a you know a very
popular platform so how do you continue
for it is a two-part question first how
do you continue to iterate on
creativeLIVE to make sure that you're in
lockstep with what's happening
culturally and secondarily as this
visionary what is the next thing around
the bend that you're seeing right now
step one is I don't think that I'm I let
the pop culture be my guide so much as
my intuition and surely pop culture's is
one of the inputs yeah but it's
transitory and ephemeral yeah and so
it's a little bit more of a feeling and
what I find is that if you're chasing
market opportunities you're always
behind and I've been willing like again
just go back to like taking pictures
with your phone I was taking pictures of
the palm treo that had point three
megapixel camera my friends thought I
was totally insane and I was like you
know what that's kind of cool because
you know the money thing that I
mentioned earlier yeah maybe it doesn't
have a role here that's just that's
actually a relief mm-hmm and I just kept
doing it and lo and behold the market
comes market intersects with your ideas
that's one cool things happen the same
thing with creative life like online
learning was so like it was so ephemeral
and wispy and don't like of course
you're gonna learn more on the internet
that's like you can see the internet
shaping up to that but it wasn't really
about schools and about
all this other kind of stuff that it is
now and the same thing but I wasn't
saying like is this a good idea should I
do this no I just kind of like what
would be cool and so I'm trying to maybe
it's a superpower but I got that
information just from being a part of
the world and letting the things that
are inspiring me inspire me and then I
tried to make something out of it which
is to me that's the takeaway and right
now you might be saying oh wait a minute
I'm not quite in tune with that or but
that's starting to listen all I'm doing
is getting much better at listening to
all these inputs that are hitting me and
I'm able to literally create something
or put something out in the world that
is a manifestation of all those feelings
so what I feel like is I'm and there's a
hundred mistakes along the way that
don't get that aren't in the news or
aren't gonna you know be a book or
whatever and we don't talk about those
but this is like I hope that I'm living
proof of basically screwing up in so
many different ways before losing so
much money and time and all those things
that I'm but I'm just now kind of
getting into the okay cool it's working
so I advocate not to be looking to your
left and to your right
you know because otherwise if you're
looking behind you you're not gonna know
where you're going and just you know you
do you go back to one of the core
missions if your show is authenticity
I'm just making things and resonate with
me that I would want to see in the world
just so happens that every once in a
while the market hits one of those
things at the right time so you know
that's sort of how I think about not to
dodge the question about how do you keep
creative live relevant but Kraig lodge
is gonna keep doing its thing and
they're you know that's his own
ecosystem and life and it's gonna keep
evolving and changing and growing as as
companies that are like people they may
become but behind that sorry to
interject behind that I think look we've
sort of set it up as as your opportunity
to give back and to contribute and
cultivate community around these subject
matters that are important to you but
but I think that overlooks the broader
intention here and an understanding
which is that fundamentally education
needs a reboot right like we're we're
stuck in an archaic
setup that isn't necessarily serving
young people for the world in which we
now live yeah very true and again
there's no evil genius no one is trying
to keep you down but part of a mass
culture is that you need to create a
system that can manage the most people
the most efficiently and we've done a
very good job of that and in the means
of production world it's called the
factory and in the education world
that's called a school and we put raw
material in one end and we move it down
the assembly line at the same time when
we inject the same things into the same
molds at the same moment and then at the
end what do we create in the factory
it's a widget in a school it is a person
who went through the school system and
the reality is that school system and
sadly the persons or people that were
making in those systems are woefully
unprepared for what the future has
because this system both the system the
means of production in a factory and the
means of education in a school are very
slow to adopt their de incentivized and
in fact the government makes a huge sum
of money on giving you easy access to
student loans its student loans 1.5
trillion is the debt and student loans
in our country which is higher than
credit card debt just grab onto that for
a second and will never go away it'll
never go away it's an unforgivable from
you file bankruptcy it doesn't matter
right so and again I'm not throwing
rocks at our government or at the school
system or the but it's just an awareness
that we have to realize that we need to
now supplement all of these things both
our career if our parents had one job
you and I are gonna have five the next
generation is gonna have five at the
same time is a building covered with Ivy
on a hill that you have to pay 60 grand
a year gonna prepare you for that no and
my wife is as a public schoolteacher for
years I rummaged around in the boiler
room of the school to find enough desks
to put them in her class we paid for all
the materials on the walls of her
classroom because we cared but it's just
and and I don't again the goal is not to
throw rocks at the school system because
it does a very good job
of a very simple foundational deal but
what I'm trying to emphasize here is
that's not enough I do I am very excited
to share I've this is the second time
I've put this out in the world and I'm
gonna so I'm gonna do it here that I'm
trying to gather for people who want to
contribute I'm trying to gather there
are 3,200 teachers in the Seattle School
District and I want to get 3,200 books
there's a hundred and thirteen schools I
found some one whole dropship boxes to
all these schools so if I can find a way
to get enough 3,200 books I'm gonna give
a book to every school teacher in the
outlook school as a mechanism for both
just connecting with them and helping
them understand this sort of where I
think the future is in the role of
creativity in it if somebody's listening
to this they want to help you with that
what's the best way for them to do that
I first of all thank you go to creative
calling calm and there's some bonus with
purchase if you bought the book one
bonus is you can get into a class that
creativeLIVE for free it's a special
class another one is if you want to like
buy ten books then I don't know what you
get you get something else and then some
goodie bag yeah and then there's another
one that says make me an offer and that
is like if you want me to come speak or
whatever and what I just mentioned this
and I've already had two people
contribute here you can just send me an
email and say I want to contribute this
much and we have a mechanism I'll handle
these in a one-off manner right and I
was just on a show and someone came
through with boom 100 books you know
it's like to me this is what the cool
part of the Internet and the time we're
living in right now is that we can put a
dream out there in the world and you
just wanted to talk about the school
system and we can acknowledge
acknowledge the shortcomings and do
something about it which is super
exciting for me
so that's a little aside but I would
love it if you want to join and help in
that mission I think it's and the
aspiration is to do it in Seattle and
then if it works like right make it a
program yeah make it rock like a totally
but to go back to the the
and the the school system that you were
I think appropriately calling out no
evil genius but we have to take our
education into our own hands and that is
why things like books podcasts learning
platforms are an essential part of any
person's learning experience going
forward this is true about true with
your kids it's true with us I don't know
why learning should stop at age 18 or 21
or whenever you finish high school or
college or whatever
it shouldn't that's a myth that's that's
when you're supposed to go into the
factory literally
and again there's like we can both
acknowledge that and decide to take
different action and that's what I'm
asking yeah well it's really cool what
you create it and I'm not gonna let you
off the hook on the one on the one thing
about what's around the bend yeah I
think do you mean in terms of in sort of
I'm talking about like trends like okay
you you because you're immersed in your
internet culture or you pay attention to
you have a way of canvassing kind of
what's happening and have developed the
acumen for a little bit of foresight of
what's to come so my question is really
like what do you see like just around
the bend that you think is gonna be
something we should be thinking about
now radical decentralization of lots of
different things
radical decentralization so let me take
two things yet some money is happening
let's take two things that we've just
been talking about let's talk about
education and then we're talking about
workforce so education we just described
the radical decentralization of
education it's not happening in a
building covered with Ivy on a hill
where they have billions of dollars or
the real estate in the middle of Boston
your education is not happening there
your education is out in the world with
all these radical dynamic inputs and
your learning is going to be a lot more
tied to those inputs and where you want
to go in the work force the factory is a
the knowledge workers are and that's not
to say that we don't need a factory
great and there are people for whom a
factory is the perfect thing and I'm a
huge advocate of the trades and not
everyone should go to college and it
isn't really about it doesn't define who
we are the reality though is that 50
million Americans I think it's by 2020
are gonna have a side hustle that means
half of the working population of the
United States will be making money
outside of what would they would
typically call their job and to mean
that open that is like a massive world
of opportunity and now I want to go step
one step removed and say what role does
creativity play in those two things
everything critically central write
critically central it means everything
like you have to create your own
educational arc you have to create a way
to learn in the world that you're moving
through today you have to yeah you I
don't need to you know to be pedantic
but and if you look at the trend that I
see in this radical decentralization is
opportunity I think we mentioned Seth
Godin earlier Seth has a quote in in the
book about it's just about like
preparing us for the new opportunities
and that's the way I think about you
know the timing of this book that what's
the guts of the book is fulfillment all
those things are there at the core but
it's also like everybody says like oh
like creativity is so whimsical and
playful and naive it's the most
practical thing we've gotten yeah I mean
I think you nailed it completely you
know we're seeing this explosion of the
freelance workforce the whole notion of
career has been upended young people go
from gig to gig to gig multiple gigs at
a time as you said the workplace is now
that we works in the co-working space
and remote or the Starbucks where we are
yeah exactly every everything is
decentralized you know we could get we
could you know from Bitcoin to office
space which
means the individual it's incumbent upon
the individual to take control and
responsibility for what that arc is
going to look like and that's the space
in which creativity can make the
difference between a you know a sort of
reactive path versus a very intentional
path that would you know flourish into
the life that you aspire to have I
cannot say yeah I will add nothing to
that and on top of that I would put I
would put a veneer on top of that of
this increase we're seeing in in how we
think about ownership young people
they're not angling to it used to be
like the house in the car the you know
front yard and all that it's like they
don't care about any of that it's it's
about you know maybe a tiny house or
living in a van or or just being a a
what do you call it like the the when
you're constantly traveling no no me
yeah like a digital nomad
all the way down to you know
ride-sharing
everything is is rental based or
impermanent like now we're seeing the
growth of renting clothes like the only
time even a bike friends in mind sort of
gratefully Romney where you don't have
to own anything golf club right he's so
whole idea of how you navigate the world
and what you need for self-sufficiency
is completely changed and I don't think
that we're in a place you have to fully
appreciate how that's gonna play out but
psychically mentally you know how does
that inform the choices that the next
generation is going to make about how
they want to live their lives or that
you should make start yeah right now
exactly like I'm an old man but like I I
you know I don't yeah back to the word
calcified like you know I'm always
trying to prevent myself from from
getting set in my ways you know so that
I can be nimble in this regard but I
think you're you totally nailed it well
if you're calcified then I'm like I
don't know what I am now notice I'm like
sitting over here pouting in the corner
no no no dude thank you all right we're
going to wrap this up the book as I said
at the very outset is is brilliant
super proud of you and I'm super excited
for people to not only experience it but
put the wisdom to work in their own
lives and and let's see a lot of lives
changed thank you so much it means the
world to be able to be on the show love
what you build of the community and it's
just just a treat so thanks for having
me but yeah likewise as I said on on
your show your your legacy and your
example was inspirational and me
wrapping my head around trying to do
something in this space so thank you for
that on a personal level I've always had
such tremendous respect for not just the
quality of the work that you put out in
the world but like the way that you
share it in that transparent and
authentic manner and it's beautiful
thing and I wish you only beauty success
and love my friend amazing thanks but
appreciate it
so if people want to pick up the book
obviously Amazon your favorite
independent bookseller but creative
calling calm is the website where you
can learn more about all the perks and
bells and whistles yeah yep and that or
yeah that's a great place to go create a
creative live comm slash creative
calling as well okay special classes if
you've already bought the book you can
enter your receipt there and get access
to some cool stuff but yeah and I'm just
at Chase Jarvis yeah if you start typing
chase in Google it'll pull his name up
and you'll be able to find all his stuff
but you're basically Chase Jarvis
everywhere if the Chase Jarvis live-show
Chase Jarvis raw your YouTube channel
all your good stuff right thanks for ya
all the shouts out I appreciate it and
thanks for everything having me on the
show it means a ton to me I'm Horace and
that means a lot that you came out here
so appreciate it brother sweet peace
[Music]